taiwan's defense minister says relations
with china are at their worst in four
decades the comments come after china
used dozens of fighter jets and a
demonstration of force over several days
flying them through the taiwanese air
defense zone while it isn't technically
taiwanese territory being in the area is
seen as provocative taiwan considers
itself a sovereign state beijing however
views it as a breakaway province
and joining us now from taipei is our
correspondent joyce lee let's see if we
can see her hi joyce that is a very very
stark statement there from the defense
minister how did we get to this
yeah this is the
worst military tension in 40 years i
could in according to the defense
minister
he warned of a
misfire today and he said that by 2025
china would have the capability to
launch a full-scale invasion so um and
this is the first clear
message to the public that taiwan is
facing a threat of war and
although the chinese authorities haven't
made any public comments yet but
observers are
concerned that if domestic
discontent and economic slowdown is
getting serious in china taiwan would
become a target
these incursions by beijing happen again
and again how concerned are the people
of taiwan about this
well the mood is quite different on the
streets in taipei uh i spoke to um a lot
of people here on the street and
a lot of them
uh it's
it's just um part of everyday life
because uh
since two years ago
chinese military jets fly over to
taiwan's defense zone on a weekly or
even daily basis so it's become a new
normal for two years already but fears
are definitely growing here especially
after the comments made by the defense
minister
taiwan has been making moves towards
independence how much support is it
getting from its allies notably the u.s
u.s president joe biden
said on tuesday that he has spoken to
president xi jinping about taiwan and
they agreed to abide by the taiwan
agreement
it appears that biden is referring to
the long-standing one china policy under
which it recognizes china rather than
taiwan so um
but at the same time
the u.s also reassured taiwan that
its commitment to taiwan is rock solid
and it will continue to help taiwan
defend itself
joyce lee in taipei thank you very much
you